Colin Kaepernick says he knows his white
adoptive parents loved him but they were
very problematic things that occurred
during his upbringing oh your hair is
not professional oh you look like a
little Thug Oh my God oh my God
a parent didn't like their kids haircut
never has happened in history welcome to
being a child and having parents as a
black man who used to be a black boy
black teenager uh when I had an afro and
I was getting cornrows and stuff same
thing happened to me anything happened
and I don't have white people especially
when I was getting in trouble in school
he made me cut my hair because for
whatever reason me having a big afro and
wanting to get cornrows and wearing
Chuck Taylors equated to me wanting to
be a thug or I'll never be able to get a
good job or anything else like I don't
think that's something that's exclusive
to race if you see everything through
that lens then you'll always find racism
and and what the problem is then when
real racism racism shows up you don't
even know what to do with it